[Music]
[Music]
come on let's go
[Music]
come and get me [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is he doing here
we found your daughter she's alive
be prepared for changes we have a child
therapist that she'll be working with
four years is a long time what she needs
right now is her family mister
sweetheart
it's mommy
welcome home esther we left it just as
it was
it's lovely to be back i miss my family
very much
our goal here is helping esther
acclimate back into life within the
family unit
[Music]
sorry
i think something's going on with esther
is there anything you want to tell me
about your time away
how's that possible four years ago she
was still drawing stick figures
esther's behavior has been so erratic
hello mommy
thank you mommy
i did notice some inconsistencies
what are you getting at
to me it felt like a performance
if you're not esther who are you
[Music]
i mean it's for you
and let your poor heart
break a little
that's the story of
the story
the story of
the
the mother protects her family
no matter what
that's the glory of love
[Music]
i'm so sorry i forgot to tell you but
you're not feeling very well and the
only way to cure it is if we stay home
[Music]
[Music]
victory is safe and secure
here you can live the life you deserve
we can all live
frank has built something truly special
what he's created out here it's it's a
different way
a better way
victory has things money can't buy
i lived next door you wouldn't believe
the things i've heard
jack and alice only have time for each
other
what is the
enemy of progress chaos yes
nasty word
chaos
the one thing they ask of us is to stay
here
where it's safe
i was here when you got here
yeah
you sleep in the bedroom
[Music]
that's good just breathe
most of my patients have had nightmares
i have some pills i can prescribe for
that
violet where did you meet phil we met on
a train to boston you dropped your
ticket and he bent down picked it up
gave it to you right
thank you for your loyalty
not everyone gets this opportunity
what are we doing changing the world
what are we doing changing the world
they're lying about everything
keep calm and carry on
i gave you all of your solace it's all
about control
i know exactly who you are
been waiting for someone like you
someone
to challenge me
like a good girl
here's the thing we're a team of thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
revenge
truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it
so how do we pull that off
uh
figure it out over a drink probably best
you need
to give us a fighting chance we're gonna
need strength you got this right i know
you don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's an owl there
[Music]
be warned
there is evil here
i'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this i'm
a planner i make plans you've already
made plans so if the existing plan fails
i make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant
bella so good to see you i'm sorry it's
under such terrible circumstances yeah
it's fine when your father passed he
left you something
very funny is that a jerk
no congratulations you have a boat right
i have a part
cheers cheers
i know a place we can go
[Music]
hey no one's supposed to be out here
get your hands up
[Music]
wake up the parts moving
four mechanical locks
if we get through all those
we saw the biometric lock we gotta get
off this one
i don't swim i'm gonna help
[Music]
push the red button
[Music]
kill her
[Music]
he stole my part
danny yeah had a chance to read that
article you sent me what do you think
you don't feel like it comes off a
little tone deaf
offensive even i don't feel like you
take me seriously as a writer that's
because you're not a writer
you're a photo editor
have you ever wanted to be noticed so
badly hey mom you want to hang out
tonight
you didn't even care what it was for
holland oh [ __ ] what up bunny danny from
work danny yo colin i love your videos
man
thanks b
so what are you i'm a writer
i'm looking to develop my work by
traveling
going to paris for it
[ __ ]
hey get picked i'm gonna get lots of
pics yeah i'll throw them all up on the
ground right
[ __ ]
emma i got invited to a writer's retreat
in paris
yes really
starting my morning right now where's my
baguette
[Music]
we have some breaking news at this hour
a string of terrorist attacks struck
paris this morning
leaving dozens dead and many more
injured
[ __ ]
like 26.77 now arriving
danny she's okay
we are here with the girl of the moment
you've been blowing up our insta feet
speaking of bombings
really glad you're not good me too
isn't she so strong everybody
oh my god you're the girl from the paris
attack
let's not forget the signature red beret
hi i'm danny rowan welcome to group
we're all survivors here do you want to
share
you're not okay that's okay
the internet likes to turn victims into
villains
oh no it doesn't seem to be happening to
me
you should be prepared if it does
we need to talk
be careful what you [ __ ] wish for
so what are we supposed to feel bad for
you
[Music]
how long have you been writing about us
he lived his life for himself
and then it shifted
[Music]
has so many demons i was young in love
and i was terrified
but he's trying to be better for me
i just keep dragging you into my [ __ ]
testing his mouth
[Music]
i don't know if i can keep fighting to
save him rather than myself
we need time apart
you can't just escape yourself by moving
from one place to another
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a bidding war for my book
i don't want people reading about my
life this is our lives what is the point
in everything we've been through if we
can't channel that into something that
helps people it's about forgiveness and
unconditional love that is the kind of
story after us
after
it's my journey after i met you
[Music]
[Music]
you're gonna get arrested you know that
which is why you should leave
you weren't here when she needed you now
you're making it worse
[Music]
you are pushing every ounce of my
self-control you have no idea
[Music]
you've been at this what
40 years
50.
come downstairs
you won't believe what we found
a kid had been in this cage
we're looking for a girl
it still gets you riled up
how the hell can it not
how is your morning drivers i got a
beautiful day here
it's good to know you ladies are out
there
i have not been this excited to see you
since you came for mom
you said that was last time
i asked for one
where's the package
[Music]
you don't understand i don't take people
no way i can promise what'll happen to
your brother if you don't take the girl
where she needs to go
you're driving you're not suggesting we
go analog to every truck stop
you wanted field work this is the field
it was a girl dennis what do you mean
the package was a girl what
what happened
we're in this together
there was some bad people wanting to
hurt that girl these guys have eyes all
over the state
we just got to get the girl back and
then they'll let us off the hook i don't
want to give it back
[Music]
are you gonna be okay you're in
dangerousness that's what matters
[Music]
i just want to help her and whoever's
trying to be good to her
i joined the bureau so i could mean
something to someone
[Music]
you're lucky to know where you want to
go
i only know what i'm running from
just keep the girl close she's our
lifeline
[Music]
[Music]
last thing we need is a bunch of
complaining after them with guns
she needs us
the way we needed each other
why'd you join
doesn't matter why i joined only matters
what i do with it
hey lizzy with my nine o'clock
sorry about the game but we're gonna
have fun tonight
let me guess another it conference i'm
gonna be back in a couple days toms hey
mom dad has a work emergency so can you
come pick me up i love it when you call
me mom let's throw a rager
what's happening
please don't touch me
[Music]
this is so tight
it's some kind of superhero lair your
dad's a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
step step step into the spotlight
i have a crazy idea
step into the spotlight
please don't kill me
now that's fast
we got him
[Music]
whoever has this technology can do
anything
we gotta save my dad's tech before they
destroy the world
we got this
what are you gonna do tickle torture me
oh dude that was too long
that was way too long
whoa don't you i'm the i.t guy i was
alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am i supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right
yes
playtime's over kids
prepare for war
[Music]
things are warm
yeah so hot you got the winter suit
[Music]
these sessions are mandatory for all
staff sister anne
my mother struggled with depression
annie annie honey can i come in
but even as a child i knew it was danny
open the door please
more
[Music]
my mother talked about hearing that
voice inside
she said the voice didn't really want
her
it wanted me
the citadel has fallen black smoke
blocks out the sun because as some of
you may already know we have a female
student in the class only as an observer
so
let's descend into the mouth of hell
shall we
there are more possessions reported
today than at any other time in history
certainly must fight for every soul
[Music]
defend us in battle against the spirits
of wickedness
[Music]
i believe the demon that is tormenting
natalie and the demon that possessed my
mother are one in the same
i'd like to teach sister just enough to
protect herself and others
this relationship she
it's
has
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
your mother has a pretty voice
hello
be careful
once you know the devil
the devil's knows you
[Music]
you ever heard of creeper
a local legend right
the creeper comes back every 23 years
then what
[Music]
can't believe i let you drag me to this
this is the coachella of cosplay
the grand prize is
an escape room for two
creepy
[Music]
are you sure this is where we're
supposed to be
we'll be out there in no time
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell is that
it's a
trap
there's no way else
come on
ah
[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen i'm
guessing that some of you
you're not happy maybe you don't fit in
people make fun of you
well i can't make you straight
but you give us this week and we might
be able to help
voice cabinet over there girls cabin
over there i use they them pronouns as
in they can't believe they're at this
camp
i have zero interest in not being gay
there's no judgments in this room
sometimes always sure was invisible
i would understand it a lot more if
there was bible thumping and queer
bashing do you even believe in any of
this
come in please
do you think your parents are
disappointed in you sometimes so what do
you do you try to make yourself
special
you
become
a
today we're going to be exploring
traditional gender roles
look how long they've been doing this
it's time to play
this could get a lot worse where's my
killer
we need to get out of here
taste
just enjoy the sunshine and work on your
tent
they slash them
streaming only on peacock august 5th
their wife is ready to go home her
vitals brain activity and battery have
all been charged and are ready for
companionship
how do you feel
feel
familiar
[Music]
they are people too they're becoming
more and more aware they need rights no
more sex slaves
why would someone steal a companion
it's not a stone it's an organization
we're running out of time meredith
we need you to remember
remember what
let's get a good look at the guy her
she said she ran narrative off her path
on purpose
william told me how you people steal
companions you reprogram them to do
awful things i need to speak to merry
inventor
now she mentioned a man in the mask the
one who hacked into my dreams she says
he and i go way back
how are we connected
hi kind of a minute of your time what's
your name
i
remember
this isn't love
i remember everything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a crooked federal agent helping
a sex trafficker smuggle women into the
country but he's watching our every move
beds are 30 minutes out we need to move
now
someone tipped them off
place is empty our resources are
compromised sneaking these women in is a
lot easier if you have a border patrol
chief in your pocket have you lost your
mind you don't just arrest him on a
hunch it was more than a hunt shut up
stay in your lane sergeant there are
protocols
i am so happy to find you alive they
killed everyone but me and now they want
me dead because i can identify every
last one of them
look the other way
this isn't as for forgiveness not
permission situation
what are you suggesting
we will see our old friend
i see you too wait
what do you want
we need you
they need your help so that these
animals can't do it to another group of
girls
what's the plan
we need anything you can find on the
location date time where and when
they're bringing a text thread with an
address to a shipping yard shipping
container id etc will that do i never
show off aren't you okay
let's get to work
i don't have to look the other way i've
got nothing to lose
ready or not
here i come
just breathe
[Music]
[Music]
your singing was amazing tonight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
an egyptian sarcophagus
huh mommy let's not touch anything
i'm sorry you were saying
oh
ah your face what happened to my face
you're cursed
these curses get permanent if you don't
cure them soon
yeah oh what's the plan
let's move before it's too late
mommy doesn't have that much time left
i want to see the world
[Music]
ransom bandages thanks i get that a lot
what did you do to the moto lisa i fixed
it
a wrinkle
you don't have to be nervous
i'm not nervous
well so impressive you're impressive
they're going to be obsessed with you
i just want to feel good they're not as
nihilistic as they look on the internet
you guys this is me oh
whoa this is your first relationship i
don't know you just kind of give that
vibe
oh you know that has weed in there right
[Applause]
[Music]
who wants to play body spotty spotties
so how do you play
if you draw the piece of paper that has
the x on it you are the murderer let's
go
and if you're the murderer you have to
kill someone by touching them on the
back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
is that the lights
david
if i were the
killer for the neighbors
[Applause]
[Music]
safe really because it looks like you're
grabbing a meat cleaver to go look for
my boyfriend
[Applause]
you should watch a girl
[Music]
i brought something what is it
it's zucchini bread
yum oh girl pop girl rich girl i'm a
girl false girl catch me if you can't
[Music]
[Music]
a horrible thing happened to you
i just want you to be able to move on
with your life
come here it's coming up on a year
i have something that's planned and i
need a partner in crime the b67 tv tower
i haven't climbed since becky if you
don't confront your fears you are always
going to be afraid
let's do it
let's climb your stupid tower
i'm so excited
[Music]
i was really ripped you're awesome that
is the becky that we need for this trip
this is sick
damn it hunter what are you getting us
into
okay so just stay behind me one wrong at
a time
[Music]
see
it's easy
you're doing great
becky you gotta
hey trust me
what was that
[Music]
puncher how do we get down
i don't have a
the
signal
is down there in that bag we have 50
feet of rope
i think i could drop myself lower
okay i'm going to jump onto the
fabric every hour that passes the weaker
we get if anyone called 9-1-1 they'd be
here by now
what is it that dan used to say if
you're scared of dying don't be afraid
i design people's homes
i'm being asked to pick out seasonal
living room furniture i don't even know
if i feel creative anymore
i think you should take some time off
disconnect the digital detox
hey it's sophie carter your guest just
let me know where i should meet you
[Music]
i'm michael i'm the owner of sunset
terrace this is my daughter
grandmother meredith used to come here
she was a painter you're not becoming
one of them are you one of what a
teenager
[Music]
do you still have meetups for artists
here no i thought about selling sunset
terrace after natalie died i feel like
the most insensitive guest ever oh no
that was no bother we are way too late
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna try to be a
little bit ruder move it or lose it oh
that's rude i like it
there's this place that is really
popular with local artists you know i
can show you
ready to go
come on i'm painting you in my mind and
what do i look like joyfully
[Music]
good morning sleeping beauty
nice pajamas buddies
it's perfect here
i don't know that i'm ready to come back
yet we've got work to do sophie i can't
just let my business fall apart i'm
sorry michael
sophie's going to be leaving
with you and kaylee
the happiest i've ever been
sometimes you have to change because you
don't have a choice
so you should change it while you can i
want to be here following my heart
[Music]
hello june hello jennifer
i've recorded some questions here and
i've left enough space
for you to answer
[Music]
what do you think of your new school
which do you like better
sunshine or rain
he spoke to me and then it was just less
and less you know
if there's something you want to
communicate
you best say it now
[Music]
jennifer
[Music]
how would you describe your
personalities i think you might be a bad
influence on each other it might be an
idea to split you up for a while
we will move the girls into special
education are you going to say anything
they shall be institutionalized
indefinitely
[Applause]
if you were telling your story
how would it begin
in order to try out a good book you need
to feel it you have to be inspired
[Music]
my sister
it's brought a new awakening in me i
could reach out and touch the star i can
see the galaxy can't go back to the
empty days before we found out
i'm swimming in a pool taste the
bittersweet smell of salt
it's like god gave me a challenge
a challenge to prove who i really am
[Music]
why is sexual harassment so pervasive
and so hard to address
let's interrogate the whole system
hi my name is jody cantor i'm an
investigative reporter for the new york
times
what have you got i was told that the
wrongdoing in hollywood is overwhelming
i don't want to be quoted period
understood
in your previous stories how did you
persuade women to tell you what had
happened to them
a case i made was i can't change what
happened to you in the past
but together we may be able to help
protect other people
the truth basically
what is it exactly that we're looking at
here these young women walked into what
they all had reason to believe were
business meetings i can still see it the
hotel room the floor plan
he kept trying to touch me
i
asked him to leave me alone
instead they say he met them with
threats and sexual demands i was young
scared hi
we're from the new york times i believe
he used to work for harvey weinstein
[Music]
people have tried to write this story
before he kills it every time harvey
adamantly denies any allegation of
result he played people he was a master
manipulator
will you give me just one chance to talk
to you are you sure that this isn't just
young women who want to sleep with a
movie producer to try to get ahead
this is bigger than weinstein this is
about the system protecting abusers
the women who receive these settlements
they can't speak out they'll be sued if
they do but if someone could speak
freely about the payouts
what payouts john
you have to imagine that every call you
make has been recorded and you're being
followed can you imagine how many
harveys there are out there you want to
get me killed
do you wish you hadn't signed up for
this story do you
no
the only way these women are going to go
on the record is if they all jump
together
we're all here harvey who
have you talked to
i have three daughters and i don't want
them to ever accept abuse or bullying
i'll go on the record
go right
it's time to write
this is all gonna come
up i was silenced i want my voice back
[Music]
uh
so
[Applause]
rob zombie the director of house of a
thousand corpses halloween and the
devil's rejects brings you the greatest
love story ever told
oh i i don't like the sound of that
think of it
the brain of a super genius transplanted
into the body of a perfect
physical specimen
i want a man that makes my blood run
cold
a man that every time he enters my crypt
it's like a steak through my dead black
heart
i can whip the upper hubby down in the
lab oh no remember what happened last
time he was patty
i'm gonna go
okay
i'm looking for a vision
a queen true love
what exactly do you want is herman
munster in there
i knew the moment i laid eyes on you
that you were special
i understand if you don't feel the same
i'm just a regular gal living a boring
normal life
if there's one thing i know is that the
rest of the world melted away
as soon as you approach my life it seems
miss lily is truly loved oh come on you
know and i know that we gotta get rid of
that bozo herman munster
[Music]
greetings from
[Music]
transylvania that's a strange way of
saying hello oh i guess we're gonna have
to get used to it
[Music]
it takes a lot of courage to make your
own path
i was that girl in the audience dreaming
for a bigger life
[Music]
my two biggest fears were the rapture
and my family getting deported
[Music]
and then five years ago
my brother jose was deported
[Music]
and then we spend our lives with the
pressure to honor their sacrifices
music became my sanctuary
[Music]
but dreaming big takes a toll
it's too much too much i need to figure
out what my next move is
[Music]
i think i've just discovered someone
special
did she there's this
manage cucco then what makes you think
she couldn't do the same for you
the blood sweat and tears that go into
this
mean something to someone
we inherit our family's dreams
but also their fears i don't want you to
feel alone
in this moment of like how much pressure
it feels like
we hurt but we do we can't heal you're a
latina
and it's something powerful
[Music]
you